Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Ben bugün vicdan üzerine
konuşacağım biraz.
Çok güldürmeyebilir,
bazen üzebilir, biraz düşündürebilir.
Biraz kendi hikâyemi anlatacağım,
kendi vicdan evrimimi anlatacağım aslında,
öyle diyebilirim.
Ortaokuldaydım ben Ankara'dayken
tipik bir Ankara çocuğuyum
işte TED Ankara Kolejine gidiyorum falan,
beyaz türk Ankaralısı.
Et yemeyi bırakmaya karar verdim
çünkü şu fikir çok garip geliyordu bana.
Böyle bir şey yani,
annesini özleyen bağıran koşan,
sevilen falan bir şeyin kafasını kesip
yemek biraz garip geliyordu.
Aslında her zaman biraz garip geliyordu
ama annem kandırıyordu beni.
Sonra itiraf ediyor böyle,
"Evladım bu tavuklar gerçek tavuk değil,
onlar kafasız üretiliyor,
bunların kafası yok."
Yıllarca kandırıldım, sonra ortaokulda
"Bunların kafası var
ve kesiliyor yalnız falan"ı idrak edince
bir daha hiç et yemek istemedim.
Çok da isyankar bir tip olduğum için,
tahmin edebileceğiniz üzere,
bir de ergenlikle karışınca
hiç ses etmedi yani,
"Aman yeme evladım, bize bulaşma da
ne yaparsan yap!" dediler.
O zamanlar Ankara daha değişikti,
aslında sadece kebapçı vardı özünde.
Dışarıda yemek yiyeceksiniz;
kebapçı var, McDonald's falan yeni açılmış
önünde kuyruklar var,
başka bir şey yoktu.
Dolayısıyla
"Ya etsiz bir şey var mı?" denince
"Tavuk, köfte var" diyorlardı.
"Tavuk olur mu, köfte olur mu?"
Yani, balık zaten derler
Ankara'da en tazesi falan diye
ama o kadar yaygın değil.
Neyse, ama daha o zamanlar
süt ürünleri tüketiyordum
çünkü süt ürünleri tüketirken
orada kimsenin canının yanmadığını
düşünüyordum açıkçası.
İşte kaşarlı tostla idare etmece,
pizzayı sade yemece falan,
böyle böyle idare ediyordum.
Onun dışında benim ailem Egeli,
dolayısıyla evde
bol bol sebze yemeği pişiyor.
Böyle büyüdüm ve bu bana normal geldi.
Bunu sorgulamadım,
yani benim için
et yenen bir şey değil artık.
Neredeyse 25 senedir düşünsenize,
ha plastik görmüşüm
ha et görmüşüm.
Benim için aynı şey.
Fakat sonra insan 30 yaşına geldiği zaman,
başka bir şey oluyor.
Bir şey böyle "click" ediyor
insanın kafasında.
Yediğin içtiğin şeylerin
ne olduğu konusunda
biraz daha kafa yormaya başlıyorsun.
Ne bileyim biraz daha kendine mi
dönüyorsun herhalde ne oluyor.
Bu süt meselesi.
Süt beyaz bir şey,
hep böyle berraklığın sembolü,
temizliğin sembolü falan ya;
hakikâten öyle mi, değil mi?
Biraz bu konu üzerine
okumaya araştırmaya başladım
ve sütün korkunç bir şey olduğunu
öğrendim aslında.
Biraz onu sizle paylaşacağım.
Şimdi normalde
biz memeli hayvanlarız burada,
hiçbirimizin sütü var mı?
Yani yok, değil mi?
Sütümüz akmıyor yerlere şarıl şarıl.
Sadece çocuğumuz olduğu zaman dişiysek
bedenimiz süt üretmeye başlıyor
ve o çocuğu beslemek için
aslında biz o sütü üretiyoruz.
Bu, tüm memeli hayvanlar için geçerli.
Bunu hiçbirimiz bilmiyoruz mesela,
sanıyoruz ki böyle
efendime söyleyeyim inektir koyundur
bunların hep böyle
doğduğu günden itibaren
şarıl şarıl sütü akıyor
işte biz içelim diye falan,
öyle bir durum yok.
Normal inek de koyun da,
bu hayvanların dişileri
hamile kaldıkları zaman çocuklarını
beslemek için süt üretmeye başlıyorlar.
Ama günümüzün sanayi hayvancılık
dünyasında şöyle oluyor;
bu zavallı hayvancağızlar bir kere
normalde sürü hâlinde yaşarken
bizler gibi işte,
erkeğini beğeniyor, dişisini beğeniyor
arasında kavga ediyor, çiftleşiyor.
Böyle bir aşk hayatları var aslında,
sadece insanların aşk hayatı yok ki.
Tabii bu zavallı hayvancağızların
çiftliklerde tutulan
bir aşk hayatı olma şansı yok.
Öyle bir hakları yok,
o hakları ellerinden alınmış.
Ama yani hatırlayın, bunlar da canlılar
korkan canlılar.
Ne bileyim, gök gürlüyor korkuyorlar.
İşte ne bileyim, birbirlerini seviyorlar
ya da sevmiyorlar.
Kızıyorlar, kavga ediyorlar,
bizler gibi canlılar aslında.
Ama işte şu kadar bir yere tıkılmışlar,
dişi ise bu hayvanlar çocuk üretsin
diye zorla çiftleştiriliyor.
Yani ağır bir kelime kullanacağım ama
tecavüz ettiriliyor aslında bu hayvanlara
ve tecavüz sonucu doğan çocukları
kendilerinden bir de zorla alınıyor.
Çünkü o sütü hayvanın çocuğunun değil,
insanların içmesi lazım
ve bunun milyonlarca hayvana
sürekli yapıldığını düşünün,
bayağı korkunç bir şey, yani sistematik
bir acılar evleri gibi geliyor bana.
Şimdi o süt üretilen vesaire
süt ürünleri üretilen yerler
işin acı, gerçek tarafı bu.
O zavallı hayvancağızlar başka bir yemle
besleniyorlar, anne sütüyle değil.
Annelerinden ayrılıyorlar,
hiç görmüyorlar annelerini bir daha
ama onlar da bebek aslında,
içgüdüsel olarak bir anne istiyor.
Garip yemlerle büyütülüyorlar
daracık yerlerde.
Erkeklerse
zaten danayken kafaları kesiliyor,
öldürülüyorlar işte insanlar yesin diye.
Dişilerse hayatları tecavüz edilerek
ve süt üreterek geçiyor.
Dolayısıyla aslında bu gerçeği öğrendikçe
süt ürünü tüketememeye başladım.
Hani bu şöyle bir şey değil;
biraz veganlık böyle şey algılanıyor ya
"Abi yogacı, zengin işi" falan.
Ama böyle "Ben vegan olayım," falan
işte "Bu kimliği üstüme giyeyim,"
falan değil de;
öğrendikçe açıkçası içim almamaya başladı.
Yani böyle bir peynir falan gördüğüm zaman
o zavallı anne inekleri görmeye başladım.
Benim için bu iş böyle oldu.
Şunu sevmiyorum hiçbir zaman,
"Veganım ben! Veganlık!
Veganlar! Vegan! Veganım!" falan.
Her yerde bunu söylemeyi sevmiyorum
ama sadece et ürünleri,
süt ürünleri tüketmeyi
tercih etmediğimi insanlara
ifade etmeye çalışıyorum.
Tabii inanılmaz tepkilerle
karşılaşıyorsunuz.
Niyeyse, onu da anlamış değilim.
"Neden!" falan kızıyor insanlar.
Yani istemiyorum, yemiyorum yani.
"Proteini nereden alıyorsun!" falan.
Protein çılgınlığı var ya,
protein almazsa ölecek falan.
Ne bileyim abi, marulda da var protein.
Ne oluyor hani, Hulk Hogan mıyız?
Nedir bu protein çılgınlığı!
Ne bileyim işte bezelyede var,
mercimekte var sakin olun.
Böyle bir, hakikâten bir de bu yeni böyle
son yıllarda protein aşkı türemiş durumda.
Sanki protein almazsak
ölüp gideceğiz zannediyor herkes.
Ama hâkikaten bitkisel proteinle de
hayatınızı gayet güzel
idame ettirebiliyorsunuz.
Aldığım tepkilerden
bir tanesi bir de "Ne yiyorsun!"
O kadar garipseniyor ki,
sanki topraktan uranyum çıkartıp
yiyorum diyorum.
Ne demek ne yiyorsun;
işte ne bileyim sebze yeşillikler,
kabak, karnabahar falan yani.
Ne olabilir ki?
Beni asıl şaşırtan
bütün bunun insanlara garip gelmesi.
Bunun nesi garip,
mesela ben bunu anlamıyorum.
Şu daha mı normal;
milyonlarca hayvanı fabrika gibi
tesislerde böyle hayatı boyunca durdurup
kafasını kesmek normal de mesela,
işte "Ben sadece sebze
ve tahıl yiyeceğim," demek mi anormal?
Ben bunu bir türlü anlayamıyorum.
Şu yaşıma geldim, hâlâ anlayamıyorum.
Aldığım tepkilerden evet bir tanesi bu.
Ne yiyorsun? Niye yemiyorsun?
Proteini nereden alıyorsun?
İşte aslında bu iş çok basit,
bu işin bir formülü var.
Hekim vesaire beslenme uzmanı
varsa aranızda zaten bilir.
Evet, işte ihtiyacımız olan
bütün aminoasitler ette var.
Bitkilerde bir kısmı var.
Bir kısmı aminoasitlerin
bazı bitkide var;
bir kısmı, bazı bitkide var.
Dolayısıyla bunları eşleştiriyorsun.
Yani bizim geleneksel
kuru fasülye pilav yemeği var ya,
ya on numara bir yemek herkes için.
Çünkü 6 aminoasit bir tanesinde var,
3 aminoasit bir tanesinde var.
İkisini birlikte tükettiğin zaman
ne oluyor sana, ediyor 9 aminoasit.
İhtiyacın olan bütün aminoasitleri
bunlardan almış oluyorsun.
Şöyle bir argüman var.
Vücut bitkisel proteinlerin
hepsini sentezleyemiyor, diyorlar.
Belli bir oranda sentezleyebiliyor,
dolayısıyla işte birtakım şeylerin yanında
içmemek gerekiyor vesaire.
Demir konusunda mesela;
yeşillik yiyorsanız
çay içmemeniz gerekiyor falan
böyle küçük trick'ler var,
ama ölümcül bir şey değil.
Yani ölmüyorsun et yemediğin için.
Ama enteresan bir şekilde
hani böyle bir şablon oluşturmuş,
sanki insanoğlu et yemezse ölür diye.
Başka bir argüman mesela,
"Aslan kaplan da mı yemesin o zaman?"
Arkadaş, aslan kaplan
fabrika mı kuruyor yani?
Aslan kaplan gidiyor savanada bir tane
geyik görüyorsa avlıyor yiyor falan.
Sen fabrika kuruyorsun,
fabrika kuruyorsun
ve en korkuncu bu hayvanların
kafasını severek büyütüyorsun.
Yani küçük kuzucuk minik kuzucukken
seviyorsun mesela canım kuzucuğum falan
ertesi gün kafasını kesiyorsun.
Baldırı da ne güzel falan,
Yani burada aslında
adil olmayan bir şey var,
adil olmayan şey şu:
doğada hayvan avcıyı gördüğü zaman
"Ay avcı" diyor,
hayvan kaçıyor vesaire.
Avcı onun kaçtığını biliyor,
o da bir efor sarf ediyor.
Taktik yapıyor kafasında,
yakalıyor ve hayatını idame ettiriyor,
o da çocuklarını besliyor falan.
Tabii ki bir döngü var
ama bizim kurguladığımız kurduğumuz
bu dünyada artık bu döngü yok ki.
Burada şöyle bir şey var,
bizim diğer canlıların
yaşama hakkına karar verdiğimiz.
Neye göre karar veriyoruz?
Biz daha güçlüyüz diye mi
karar veriyoruz mesela?
Ben daha güçlüyüm,
o zaman bu koyunun yaşamaması
gerektiğine karar verdim.
O zaman hukuk nerede duruyor?
Daha güçlü bir insan,
daha az güçlü bir insanın yaşamamasına
karar verirse ne olacak?
Orada karşımıza hukuk çıkıyor, değil mi?
O zaman hukuk sadece bazı canlıları
kapsıyor, bazılarını kapsamıyor.
Biz bizi kapsamasına, ama diğer canlıları
kapsamamasına karar verdik.
Neye göre karar verdik acaba?
Kendimizi daha üstün bir yere
koyuyoruz o hayvanlardan,
neye göre daha üstün bir yere koyuyoruz?
Sanırım sadece burada
muvaffakiyete bakıyoruz.
Yani diyoruz ki, biz insanoğlu olarak
yapabiliriz kardeşim muktedirim.
Ben istersem milyonlarca hayvanı
bir yere kapatırım,
hayatları boyunca
kımıldamalarına izin vermem,
yavrularını beslemek için ürettikleri
sütleri de ellerinden alırım,
istediğim zaman da öldürürüm!
Böyle koyunca aslında
biraz korkunç değil mi?
Yani dolayısıyla biz milyonlarca canlının
yaşayıp yaşamaması gerektiğine
karar verme hakkını elimizde
bulundurduğumuzu düşünüyoruz.
Şu anda bu sistem böyle işliyor
ama hepinize tavsiye ediyorum.
Böyle propoganda falan
yapmaya çalışmıyorum ama
bir dakika, iki dakika düşünün gerçekten
böyle bir hakkımız var mı yok mu?
Bir ikincisi, dediğim gibi o adaletli o
adalet ortadan kalkıyor doğada bulunan.
Siz bu hayvanların kafasını seviyorsunuz,
kendinize güvendiriyorsunuz bir şekilde.
Onlara bakıyorsunuz,
yaralanırsa yarasını iyileştiriyorsunuz.
Güven ilişkisi kuruyorsunuz
hayvanla aranızda
ve sonra bir gün
hayvanın kafasını kesiyorsunuz.
Dolayısıyla orada adil olmayan
bir şeyler var.
Hayvan sizden kaçması gerektiğini
bilmiyor, düşünmüyor.
Sizi bir avcı olarak görmüyor,
sizi bir arkadaşı olarak görüyor.
Ne bileyim, böyle düşününce biraz sanki
arkadaşının sırtından bıçaklamak
gibi geliyor bana.
İnsanoğlu et yemeden varolabilir mi,
olabilir.
İşte Hindistan'da milyonlarca Hindu
yemiyor arkadaşlar yani,
çok bu kadar zararsız bir şey olsa
adamlar üreyemez değil mi?
Milyarlarca insan var Hindistan'da.
Örnekleri var, dolayısıyla yapılabilir.
Ben bunu biraz
vicdan evrimi olarak da görüyorum.
İnsan vicdanı.
Orta çağa dönün bakın mesela,
herkes birbirini katır kutur kesiyor,
değil mi?
Bu işte dönem dizilerinde falan da
çok rahat görebiliyorsunuz.
Gerçek orada anlatılanlar.
Ya da mesela çocukları öldürmek,
çocukları alıkoymak...
İşte bir hükümran devlet,
bir yeri işgal ediyor
ve oradaki çocukları bunlar bana
asker olacak diyor, sürüklüyor götürüyor.
Bunu o dönemde hiç sorgulayan yok.
Ya da Afrika'ya gidiyorlar,
"Aa burada deri rengi bizden farklı
insanlar var," diyorlar.
Bu insanları biz istediğimiz gibi
kullanabiliriz diye düşünüyorlar.
Çünkü o dönem insan vicdanı öyle işliyor,
hukuk da öyle işliyor.
O dönemlerde normal olan o,
anlatabiliyor muyum?
Mesela siz şimdi ne bileyim
18. yüzyıl Amerika'sına gitseniz
işte "Kölelik kötü" falan deseniz,
ya da işte Avrupa'sına gitseniz,
"Niye kötü olsun ki? İnsan kölesiz
yaşayabilir mi?" diyebilir size
orada yaşayan binlerce asil.
Ama işte insan vicdanı böyle bir şey,
dolayısıyla evet şu anda vicdani olarak
etik olduğunu düşündüğümüz şeyler
gerçekten etik mi acaba?
Bütün bu yaşadığım ne bileyim 35 yıllık
hayat beni biraz bunu düşünmeye itti
ve sonra onu sorgulamaya başladım,
"Etik mi acaba gerçekten?"
Şu anda bir hayvanı öldürmek
ve yemek bize etik geliyor.
Ama etik mi gerçekten?
Yüz yıl sonra insanlar
bunu etik bulacak mı
yoksa yüz yıl sonra bize dönüp
"Bu ne vahşi bir medeniyetmiş!
Resmen ölüm evleri kurmuşlar,
ölüm fabrikaları kurmuşlar ve milyonlarca
hayvanı burada katledip yemişler!"
mi diyecekler acaba?
Günahsız mıyız?
Hiçbirimiz günahsız değiliz mutlaka.
Hiçbirimiz sütten çıkmış ak kaşık değiliz.
Hiçbirimiz pirüpak değiliz.
Ama başka bir şeyi öldürmüyor olmak
hayatta kalmak için
ya da başka bir şeyin yavrusunun
hakkı olan şeyi almıyor olmak
açıkçası beni çok iyi hissettiriyor
ve işte ben bunu insanoğlunun
sanki vicdanının
bir değişimi, bir evrimi olarak görüyorum.
Diyorum ki siz de belki biraz
bunun üzerine düşünebilirsiniz.
Bunun umut neresinde derseniz
bence dünya daha iyi bir yer olabilir.
İnsanların daha çok
iyilik yapmayı düşündüğü,
sadece kendilerini değil de
bütün dünyadaki canlıların
yaşama hakkını düşündüğü
ve yaşama hakkına
saygı duyduğu bir yer olabilir.
Ben tabii doktor değilim,
beslenme uzmanı değilim.
Şunu diyemem size,
"Bu sağlıklı!" falan.
Ya da "Sağlıksız!" bunu diyemem,
bunu bilmiyorum.
Aslında bunun üstüne çok da düşünmüyorum
çünkü orada sağlık ölçütü neresinde?
Şimdi bir gün biri döner ve bize derse
"En sağlıklı şey insan eti," birbirimizi
mi kesip yemeye başlayacağız mesela?
Anlatabiliyor muyum, sağlık neye kadar?
Nereye kadar?
Teknoloji bu kadar ilerlemişken
2019 yılına yaklaşıyoruz,
2018 yılına yaklaşıyoruz.
Düşünsenize; insanoğlu uzayı böyle
kapı komşusu etmiş durumda.
Dolayısıyla hâlâ gerçekten
bu hayvanları toplu olarak katledip
yemek zorunda mıyız acaba?
Yoksa acaba birtakım alternatiflerle
daha iyi bir dünya,
herkesin, her canlının yaşama hakkı olduğu
bir dünya kurabilir miyiz?
Benim umudum var.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)